[Music]
i'm rachel kookaji i'm a freshman at
hillsdale college and these are my first
few days on campus
i'm really interested in going into the
medical field so i guess i'm most afraid
of
finding out that those classes are way
too hard for me
i didn't always want to go to college
because
i did like other things such as dance
but then once i decided that i wanted to
go to college i knew that to me
hillsdale
was totally different than almost any
other college it's like
every other college in hillsdale there's
really only one thing to do here
find out what things are you think you
know
you don't you're going to go through
socrates education kind he gave in the
dialogues and it's going to start right
away and it's going to start in every
discipline
now what you have to do
is you have to become a partner in this
the word
college means partnership
when i say goodbye to my family
it suddenly hit the
difference that it would be living here
versus living at home
and the fact that i really wouldn't see
them until thanksgiving
i think leading up to it i was really
excited
and at that point as excited as i was i
thought wow
i better like this because i'm here and
there's no going back
but so far i really like it so some
people ask why
i did hillsdale for pre-med but it's no
matter what major
anybody takes here we still put focus on
the language and the history of the
people that came before us and that
heritage
so that we don't forget our predecessors
and so that everybody has that base
because that is the base for
life every human community writes the
philosopher
is organized for some purpose and we
must
share the purpose and you must do that
today
starting now because you're never going
to learn these things
that will enrich your life and make you
a blessing to everyone you meet
unless you are prepared to give your
whole
being to it why do we do that
we do it for the joy of it
it'll change your life it'll make you
great
it'll do it by making you good we are
all going to do that together
and i promise we're going to be stubborn
about it
welcome class of 2022